Hi everyone, my name is Gabby Moreno
Cesar and I'm with the IBM Cloud team.
In this video we'll show you how to run batch
jobs with IBM Cloud Code Engine. Batch jobs
are pieces of code meant to perform specific
tasks at certain times of day and then stop -
for example, processing daily
records in a back-end system.
So, starting at the Code Engine "overview"
page, we are going to choose the "Run your
container image" option and give it the name
of a "batch" container image: "hmo-task"
To save time, this image has
already been built for us.
Let's go ahead and hit "Start creating"
to move on to the next step.
On this screen we can enter many different
configuration options but for now let's just
stick with the defaults for everything except
for the first one... for that we're going
to choose "Job" instead of "Application".
With that let's go ahead and hit "Create"
We have now created the definition of our Batch
Job. Meaning, we didn't actually run it yet - we
just made the platform aware of our Job. This
will allow us to run it over and over as needed.
Before we actually run the job, let's
first talk about what the job will do.
For this demo we have an application that manages
a set of customer records and our Job will process
all of the customer records in our
backend system. You don't need to
understand what the records are for, or what
this front-end application is that I'm showing.
The key things here are the two numbers that
are from our backend system. The first shows
the number of records in there, and the second
shows how many have been processed. As the batch
job runs, the second number will increase and
eventually should equal the first number.
Let's just keep this off to
the side so we can watch it.
Let's now run the batch job by
hitting the "Submit job" button.
You'll notice there are a few
options that we can modify.
First, and foremost, is the 'Array indices' field.
This tells Code Engine how many instances of the
job to execute. It's showing a default value of
"1" - but this demo we're going to run 10
of them so we're going to enter "1-10"
Code Engine allows for you to not only
specify how many instances to run,
but how those instances are numbered. Meaning,
are they numbered 1, 2, 3... or should they be
numbered 1,3,5,7, ... if we only want odd numbered
instances? Often the instance number is used a
part of the processing to ensure each instance's
work doesn't overlap with any other's.
We're going to leave the rest of the configuration
options alone and just press "Submit job".
Notice in the window that we
have 10 pending instances.
Each instance will eventually move from "pending",
to "running" and finally "completed" states
Notice in the application window you can see the
number of records processed is going up... fast.
And in a matter of seconds
all 10 jobs are completed
Let's quickly summarize what happen though. With
just the name of a container image we defined
a Job and then executed it with 10 instances.
We didn't have to do any other infrastructure
setup or management. As a developer of this code,
all I had to worry about is the business logic of
workload - nothing else.
And that's the goal of Code
Engine - allowing developers to focus
on what's important... coding.
That's all the time we have today, but hopefully
you found this quick walk-thru of how to manage
batch jobs in Code Engine exciting and I encourage
you to look at our other videos to see more key
Code Engine features. And, of course, we hope that
you'll go to www.ibm.com/cloud/code-engine to play
with it yourself.
Thank you.